all right so let's put some notation on
this maybe just do a sub hang for me
okay notation we are saying that these
two problems are two perspectives on the
same problem okay if you can work out
this total change here you can work out
this area right without having to draw
the area which means vice versa if I can
work out the area then I can work out
the total change you're solving the same
problem from just two different angles
right we're used to doing this with
auxilary angle right we said don't write
this down we said that you know this
thing here if you can state it as whoops
don't need that as this thing here right
the right-hand side is a lot easier to
work with yeah it's much easier to solve
and if you solve this thing you've
solved that right well what we're saying
here is if you can solve an area problem
you can solve this or vice versa okay so
so I had to write down some notation
here F of three take away F of one
that's the problem we solved over here
right total distance traveled is
endpoint take away start point okay but
what it's equal to is adding up these
areas they happen to be rectangles in
this case okay now because I'm summing
things up from one point to another I
don't really have notation for that I
kind of have this notation right what's
this Corian it's what Sigma notation we
use the Greek letter Sigma because it's
the closest to the English letter S
because that's what you're doing you're
adding things up right the principles
kind of similar because you're starting
somewhere and you're ending somewhere
right the problem here is I've got nice
whole numbers here from 1 to 2 then 2 to
3 but we already said it doesn't have to
be like that you could have half an hour
here
you could have 35 seconds there so where
is this thing is all to do with from or
where do we introduce this what topic in
binomial theorem and also more recently
in this too
series of sequences right both of which
are dealing with hole objects right it's
like this Plus this Plus this etc right
so they're all separate but here I could
have like weird small pieces and long
pieces and all different shapes okay so
therefore I need a new symbol the Greek
letter for s is taken so I'm just going
to take the English letter for s the
English letter for s and I'm just gonna
stretch it out okay
so this symbol here is just like this
symbol here you're summing a whole bunch
of things you still start from somewhere
and you still end somewhere now I just
need to work out where one of the things
that we're adding okay hmm rectangles
right rectangles every rectangle like
the area of a rectangle is always
something times something else it's
always apart to two things what are the
two things that I multiply length and
breadth right like the breadth is
usually the way that we say it that's
like the formula you learnt here okay
because I'm oriented on a Cartesian
plane instead of going in length and
breadth I'm gonna say hi and with the
same ideas right hi and width tell me
what the height and width are see this
height here it's on the vertical axis
but what is the vertical axis it's not
just some random thing it has a name
right the vertical axis on this graph is
this guy right that's the height of my
rectangle can I say that again that's
such an important idea I need to stare
do on this graph the height of ever
every rectangle is f dash X right
because that's what this graph is about
it doesn't make sense to say the height
here because this is not an area problem
this is an area program okay what is the
width of my rectangle hmm now remember I
said to you we I've given you a simple
problem we'd like nice neat chunks okay
but if it was like two minutes 35
seconds all that kind of thing you could
still do it couldn't you right he just
would have slightly different Messier
numbers and fractions and decimals all
that kind of thing but the one thing by
all of these is that it's about an X
value and it's changed do you see that
like suppose I said to you from one hour
and 58 minutes to two hours the total
width would be two minutes right it's a
change in X well I have language for a
change in X we use the letter D right we
use that we introduce that with first
principles right so a little change in X
a little change in Y that's dy on DX we
used to that so that's what I've got
here do you see that height and width so
what is it what are these things that I
am adding up over here I start at one I
end it three and then I just add up a
bunch of rectangles and every rectangle
is the same right
it's a height times the width except the
Heights just happened to change right
it's a height times a width that's all
that means
do you see that s for some add up a
bunch of things the things that you're
adding up are all rectangles and this is
the dimensions of the rectangles height
and width okay hmm now just for a second
rewind all the way back to the start we
were talking about an astronaut and a
velocity and displacement okay suppose
you did not know that that's what they
were right I just told you there's an F
Dash and an F okay earlier on at the end
of earlier on this turn at the end of
geometrical applications of calculus we
learned that if you start at a function
and you differentiate you get F dash
right but that actually doesn't make
sense in this context because look at
what's known and what's unknown you're
not starting from this thing and then
differentiating you get that you don't
know what this thing is F is unknown
okay but what's known is this guy right
so it actually makes sense not to call
this F but to call this F this is the
function we really know about I know the
equation of every single one of these
lines right these I don't know the
equations right so therefore I'm not
gonna call this F dash I'm gonna call
this guy F instead okay but that means
well this can't be F at the same time
right it's not going from here to a
derivative what did we call it when we
go in reverse we call this a primitive
and I introduced some language to some
notation for this I put a capital letter
there a capital F to indicate look
here's the primitive here's where you
must have come from if this is your
derivative okay so therefore if I come
over here right what I can say is well
I'm gonna replace all the little FS with
big herbs like that okay
bless you and therefore over here this F
- it's not if - anymore you see I
renamed it it's the actual function I
know something about so I'm adding up a
bunch of rectangles from here to here
and H hi is that and H width is that
okay all right
I started from our one and our three but
that was completely random wasn't it
like I could pick any numbers I like I
could have started at zero I could have
started at our 50 or something like that
so these values here sort of just
coincidental right all they mean is
here's your end after three hours I just
chose that it could be in 300 right and
he's just start yeah and that's what
they meant over here
he's your end and he's your start just
like in Sigma notation you see that like
there's a start there's the end okay so
I can write this for any not just one
and three for anything right if I
started at say a and then I went to be
start at a and it be right then the
total distance would be we'll where are
you at the end where the start right
well if I change this end and this not I
better change them over here as well
from here to here okay so just just
pause for a minute what on earth is
happening we've taken this problem which
is about like things changing over time
and a derivative right and realize that
if you're thinking about something it's
derivative you might as well be thinking
in Reverse about something and
it's primitive does that make sense okay
one last piece of notation because
you're like I don't want to write this
because there's a pain I know it's the
same thing I just put two different
values into it okay I'm going to switch
places as well I'll put this on the
left-hand side just remember what is
this thing doing this is the picture you
should have in your head when you see
that right I'm adding up a bunch of
things from somewhere to somewhere and
each thing is a rectangle right it's a
little rectangle I had to in this case I
might have five or one or fifty but I'm
just adding up a bunch of rectangles
I started from here and I solved it
through area but what if you knew area
and we're trying to solve this well you
just take that primitive take the
primitive and start here and subtract it
from ending there this is just a
shorthand way of writing this okay so
for instance you don't need to write
this I just want you to see it if I told
you this x squared from one to three it
looks like this so it would be here's
your ending point three squared
he's your ending point one squared which
is just a 9 take away one which is 8
okay I just introduced that because I
don't want to keep on writing so many
redundant things capital FS all over the
place I only need one and do the same
thing to both okay so how's your brain
doing this is a big new topic right see
this thing we're doing here putting
these rectangles together and then
getting an area the fancy word for
taking a whole bunch of things and
putting them together is integration
integration means you take a whole bunch
of little things and you combine them
into one thing they're integral their
whole that's actually where also we get
to an integer right whole whole objects
so I'm taking a whole bunch of little
separate pieces and I'm putting them
together to create a total area that's
what integration means
okay but as you've seen integration is
connected to this calculus idea right
we know that differentiating gives you
gradient but this idea of integrating
here right gives you an area gradient
area they're opposites
for some mysterious reason okay well
this is the reason this is the
illustration
okay so let's tidy this all up I want
you to write a little conclusion now the
bottom here conclusion this process here
the reverse of differentiation this is
going to be short because I don't know
much space the reverse of
differentiation is integration so the
opposite of finally a gradient
that's what differentiation does is
finding an area which is not at all the
intuitive if someone asks you what's the
opposite of hot you'd say cold what's
the opposite of up you'd say down if
someone said what's the opposite of
gradient error is not the first thing
that would come to mind okay but this
allows us to do so much because in so
many places in the world we know how
something is changing we know how fast
we're traveling we know how fast the
water is going into the fossil all we
don't know is what's the total change
and that's what integration lets us
calculate okay it's really about area